and I went to welcome to this video
playing current Gregorian there's a
child player of that strength
I don't know of his name the casino GM
but probably not this guy rating and he
doesn't he doesn't know he doesn't have
the rating and he doesn't have the title
attached to it guy taking Queen B three
years it's good if not 496 I'm going to
gamble with this see if he knows this
knight c6 is probably quite good for
black not better maybe but if he pauses
you might not he might not know it yeah
against this um White has chances for an
advantage with both actually 93 letting
black take and also with the caption c6
on b6 the reason is that still the
double points a slight problem for black
it's not super terrible but White has a
little something to play for
a three this Knight a5 maybe so
okay
not sure that rook air-five was good
looks a little bit awkward now because
he more or less has to take I think and
this is a bit awkward so he allows me to
take them even more I've got this
and tonight b5 here we go
you
okay do I just take this on this awesome
eform
hmm
yeah it's a it's a good pun to take I
think you can also play a three for
example then rook AC one and you you
just continue to pressure black it's
difficult to him to ever get this this
sorted
and Here I am not totally certain what's
best to be honest something like a three
and very slow or a form
yeah past past parts must be pushed to
some one of those funny rules of thumb
but a damn kind of its kind of right if
you have a passer pushing it is usually
quite a good idea get rid of that
hmm I thought Roxy 1 now would be quite
awkward even more trades so I can trade
everything and King see three images
King see three you know it's this is
probably going to be enough and now with
with further consideration this is
better huh just open this up
the outside person will be strong across
the could have gone by H 5 H 5 to e 8
okay look at this point so that I can go
king c5
and they were but there were ways there
were simpler ways of winning this is
what I'm trying to say but nevertheless
it should be over should be fine
and this was some kind of a model game
for this structure the problem with
taking and Queen b3 as the move knight
c6 that computer hmm for like twenty
years ago nobody really recognized that
this is an option in the first place the
idea set after this there is Bishop d7
retreating this but black gets so many
tempies cuz II five then e 4 b8 and you
have so much development why does really
am I don't really like what it was a bit
of a gamble the theoretical assessment
of this position is equal but it's not I
don't like to play it it was a bit of a
gamble as I said I usually recommend to
play Queen b3 immediately which is a
different thing after this you just play
d3 and you have slight chances of one
advantage yeah after this this is a
light sorry is a slight advantage and
this is all I think well known this is
mine this is this helps I think we
should before in the capture and then
now he made one or two more odd moves
and it got tricky you'll see one kind of
normal and after this it already felt a
bit difficult you know I'm threatening
on c6 and on f5 and it's really not so
comfortable to play now after taking it
got even more more problematic here
winning yeah it's not much fun it's very
one-sided you know my main alternative
here was a three in order to play rook
c1 but ultimately grabbing the pawn is
strong yeah push the potential passer
no no the the bishop ending is a this
was winning fairly easily right now that
I think of it actually taking this is
also quite good yeah
how does he prevent that I guess he
doesn't yeah that is that is very simple
much simple actually than what I did but
okay it's so overwhelming that Germany
that you can play a little bit weird and
so when this here I have the pawn that
is also this huge advantage in the
center with the pawns on on light
squares and ready for the taking
okay thanks for watching